hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to slime rancher now Ross
and berry told me that I needed to play
this game because it was fun and
interesting and adorable and I forget
one of the other reasons that they said
but I'm gonna play it anyway
so new game I have no idea
Oh bold bud is gonna play some slime
ranches because if there's one thing
that oh my god why do I have a gun let's
get moving let's not let's pause and
stop and contemplate the area around me
now like I said I have no idea how to
play its game
carrots do I not pick those up do slimes
not eat carrots what is it oh oh it's a
suck mobile gun it's a second it's the
succinate err it's suffering succotash
ho go fruit I don't know what that is
can I jump off I sure can well I'm so
stupid and I lost my food too
I'm off to a wonderful start sorry my
bad I'm sorry my apologies everybody
I'm so sorry for doing this stupid hello
who are you
would you like to be my friend do you
even have a face oh my god I'm sorry
that I didn't there coral hue is
scientifically proven to be the color of
cheer I don't know what that's all about
but I suck him up with my suck inator
hey little buddy you look a little lost
and happy on your own not in captivity
let's fix that problem okay so this is
slime rancher and from what Barry and
Ross told me about it it's just
literally like a everybody stop these
are the most adorable chickens come
across I am sorry everybody I am off to
the worst start in a game I've ever been
but my god that is the most adorable of
the sign for a chicken I've ever seen in
my
life I mean one it's tiny and I love
tiny I'm gonna suck you up suck I got
hand hands Oh God even their icon is
adorable oh I love this game I love it
so much
okay so what do i do hello sorry for
stepping on you sorry for sucking you up
as well but that's just you know
collateral damage at this point I can't
be held responsible for my suckage
actions suck at the game suck in the
game suck his life that's a good Court
I'm gonna put that on t-shirt suck is
life do I shoot oh god I'm sorry
I'm so sorry oh I didn't mean it suck
back up get back in my succinate er okay
tasty food required select vac tank a
coral crusted ocean floor then now
Basques under a Golden Sun well that's
all great but I still have no idea what
I'm supposed to be doing was there some
sort of instructions that I ignored us
as I flung myself face first off the
nearest cliff hello Oh God the suckage
oh it's just pure sucking devastation as
far as yet okay oh cool ah oh so I could
oh that's handy that okay so I imagine
that these are creatures that I could
put in pens back home and then feed them
food and then they're gonna get Randy in
all their gooey ways and make more slimy
babies at least that's my understanding
of how farming works
that is how farming works right you just
stuff them full of food until they make
babies right I guess that's how most of
humanity works in class that's how
babies work I mean eventually long
enough you give them enough time babies
are gonna make more babe how weird is
that like it's totally true if you keep
feeding a baby eventually it'll make
another baby how weird is that
anyway sorry I'm in a mood today all
right so uh what am i doing I have
enough these I don't think I can suck up
any more Oh God
oh sorry sir I'm so sorry ma'am sir
sorry you seem to give you be getting
your butthole stuck against my succinate
err I apologize happens to the best of
us I'll just be on my way I'm gonna
shoot some chicken somewhere I got a
chicken shooting to do okay so see I
mean why is it still giving me that tip
I know what do maybe I could put what if
I put them boink
oh that's not right how to fact like a
rancher use your suck gun to suck things
up and store them in the suck tank hold
right-mouse suck I'm okay I'm immature
so when you knocked out you'll rest at
least 12 hours in order to recover if
you're not careful you might wake up to
a mob of hungry unruly slimes on your
ranch ah slimes are key to your success
two slimes through a coral barrier into
the coral on the ranch oh oh that's
handy that oh it's kind of cruel but
it's handy oh that's cool now when do
they start [ __ ] so I feed them food
oh this is goddamn adorable can I feed
them a whole chicken nope but I'll take
some of that Oh God didn't mean to do
that sorry I'm just trying to get the
pink splurts
I just want you to this is probably
their poop that I'm collecting up and I
want a lot of but frankly I'm not being
picky when slimes eat they'll make
Florence head over to the floor t'market
to cash in on your floor it alright not
the worst thing I've heard of Oh Lord it
up can I shoot floor it's out of a suck
gun the plort market gives you new bucks
for your harder imports shoot up Lord
into the pleura market principles and
realize that they're
never all right blow it away you're
ready suck gun suck in Reverse bang bang
bang
hey boy I reverse sucked real good so I
have bucks you've learned the
fundamentals now it's time to get out
there and explore remember the best way
to become a pro Rancher is to experiment
nothing ventured nothing gained I don't
know what that means
I failed out of college I didn't fit I
didn't fail out of college I dropped out
in college there's a big difference I
mean it may not seem like this Oh JPG oh
yeah
how do I do oh it's all oh that's cool
oh that is cool oh that is cool or i'ma
suck up more ports I want to suck up a
whole bunch of more slimes and keep them
in captivity forever and ever come here
getting my suck gun where did they come
from did I just witness slime babies oh
is that what they meant by coral like
the slime babies shot out of here but
from where weird if slime babies come
from hello did you port I need all of
your delicious port not that I'm gonna
eat it or anything new area I've got a
jet pack I can deal with this I
shouldn't go in there from what I've
learned and that was a learning
experience at the beginning of this
episode I should not go into the water
because it will God cuz it will kill me
what do I do with this yeah well I tried
slamming it on my head and that didn't
work my head is the hardest thing I know
of so surely yes I don't god damn it I
don't a heartbeat
yeah Stoney and I love Stoney hens I
don't know what Stoney heads do but I
want more of them oh okay let me get rid
of those because there seem to be a lot
more fruits on the horizon
Coco fruit did I make lots of ports oh
yeah okay so I need to do something with
these hands I got it oh god I didn't
know that I could sprint like that at
least it's pretty fast first actual
commentary thing that I'll say about me
playing this game it's durable it's
lovely charming very pretty
oh god I need to buy that oh god I'm
sorry
more pink slimes for the flow what are
you doing Oh God Oh shield your eyes
kids they're [ __ ] good whooping Birds
oh my god no oh you hate that bird I did
not know that was food oh you're
horrible monstrosity Oh God do they eat
a chicken or don't they food that meat I
guess they are food oh it's so horrible
what have I done
what is that poor chicken done to
deserve it oh god Tommy what's even the
point of having slimes at my base when I
could just come out here and collect
their poop from what they harvest
normally I guess if I was being more
ambition ambitious they're probably like
rare slimes that of what is that hello
buddy
I'm gonna say hi to you you are big are
you the master of these slides oh it's
pink
Gordo give me you oh I can't suck you up
sorry sorry for attempting to suck all
over you I'm guessing you want food I
got nothing how about this oh cool money
works for me I guess ho girl fruit good
enough well that went into the vacuous
pit of nothingness that is your mouth I
guess I'll come back when I have more
food thank you very much
whoa what are you oh this so it's a cat
slam oh oh god you're adorable
oh god oh this game is so cute
what are you pink phosphor Largo Oh God
Largo slimes are large slime hybrids
formed when a slime eats up Lord unlike
its own hold the vac to keep them on
your nozzle shoot them to send them
flying boom oh my god that's so weird
so hybrid baby ports slimes what about
you oh you're a cat slime cute okay I'm
gonna I'm gonna collect some of these
Cesar no I got boot I don't know what
that means but I think it slimed all
over me
I'm not too happy about how oh god hi hi
what the hell what are you oh my god I
have no idea what what is that oh that
oh okay there's so much more oh God huh
there's so much more to this world than
I even I should not be here this is a
war going on it's not my fight this is
not my fight
I do not belong here there's apparently
slime unions with slime construct
oh you're scary oh this game so weird oh
god I didn't mean to hit you I'm sorry
oh god I gotta get out of here man I
gotta get out of here oh god this is
scary
oh man I kind of wanted to get more of
these guys okay I'll do that
Oh God at night do they just come out or
something it's that is that the deal oh
okay I'm trying to do what I can
I'm gonna save as much as these guys as
possible I've suddenly turned this into
doing this out of my own good goodwill
of my heart god those guys are scary
I'll just be on my way at least I got
two cats and three glowy glues that's a
deal Oh God more
oh these poor slimes how do I defend
them in my own home maybe I'm not an
exterminator or maybe they're doing good
maybe this is a dynamic battle of good
versus evil that I don't fully
understand yet because I'm a new element
to this world in the end I don't think
I'll ever know because I'm stupid but
other than that I try my best and I try
real hard I don't do very well like I
said dropped out of college but try my
best and that's all that matters let's
build an incinerator
whoo I should do that
boink so oh okay
I built a garden so then I should be
able to won't let me turn him up lords
have I'm buying but cool okay so now I
should be able to withdraw kirats how do
i hello wait what
and I need a food okay got food okay
here we go first time remaining forever
and ever
good god why is that so long stop trying
to escape there's only death out there
stop hey hey hey hey hey stop it I'll
suck you must suck you so bad you ain't
never gonna been sucked like this oh god
sorry okay okay good enough for you
trying to escape okay good enough okay
okay I think yeah all right god damn it
stop trying to escape he's gonna for you
okay you guys stay in there be good not
you okay all right so that is slime
rancher or at least that is the first
episode of slime rancher I actually like
this game it's adorable it's got great
art style it's got an interesting
open-world sandbox feel to it I would
wonder what this game would be like if
there was multiplayer involved and you
can play with other players doing their
slime ranches so it's great but I need
you guys as advice if you want to see
more let me know in the comments below
but also I want to play more and you
guys need to tell me what kind of
objectives I need to go for like what's
the end game of this game and where
should I take it because I could just
play it that's obvious and figure out
for myself but I'd rather get you guys
involved so let me know what you think
and thanks again for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
exciting ways
fills you up